hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to find yourself
this is a game that looked very nice and
people said that it was very scary and
i'm not putting this in a three scary
games unless you see it in one
because it seems to be of a substantial
length that it deserves to stand on a
zone
make sense good i didn't check any of
the settings i have no idea if this is
recording properly
oh well i can't move
oh oh
ah oh now i can move
okay shift to run control to crouch did
any of you [ __ ] actually write press
shift to run in a random location to
some other place in the world
i do not condone that type of mysterious
behavior
well this is spooky
hi
all right the moans will continue
funny ah hilarious
i agree um shift to run
all right cool oh
control the crouch i am looking
hi okay ignore the fact that it's kind
of bright where i'm at
i don't exactly have a lot of lighting
control oh
can i go this way no i cannot all right
i'm assuming oh left mouse to interact
oh
parking ticket
hey
you wait your turn my appointment is
with my psychotherapist very soon
so shut up and go away i'm gonna take
that thank you
did i uh hear something over here
all right whatever you say oh
the main part of the gameplay i see you
i see something not sure where that
shadow's coming from
but i'm seeing something and apparently
this is the main part of the gameplay
ah i was expecting a phone hi
where did you come from what are you hey
hey
oh don't blame anyone
try mro
i don't like this hi
hello
uh-huh
oh
[Music]
well that guy seemed to be the least
threatening monster i've ever seen in my
life
with his broke neck
hello
so okay
i'm sure that looked spectacular
oh act one monsters among us
okay good for us then
oh which way am i supposed to look stop
having so many
oh hi how's your baby
there is so much going on at once
usually in a horror game you get the
kind of
benefit of not a lot happening all at
once but this seems to have all the
things happening all at once
[Music]
oh
a pram baby
well listen it's not my baby therefore
it's not my responsibility
well then seems like i'm uh
on my own hopefully i guess that would
be the best scenario if i was on my own
hey the pram's gone
what what do you want
what are you talking about what are you
doing
oh hi
oh
my god
this is unsettling oh that what is
what is this what is ah helpful ah not
helpful
where am i high
sam calvin calvin and sam
well i can't see you now okay
interesting i'm in a child bedroom
and i don't know how i got here
well i'll just leave then nope never
mind when it gets dark mom acts weird
define weird scrap of paper there ah
the red sun lights up the path of the
white knight
is that a clue the red sun
lights up the path of the white knight
i'm guessing that's a clue of something
that i gotta do here
hello
my mother punished me and locked me in a
room after you left
dad she started treating me badly oh
mom mom
oh
oh my stuff
hi hello the red
sun finch
who's grown oh oh that ain't good
what's hiding under the bed oh i don't
know let me approach it
peek-a-boo i see you
uh-huh
uh-huh well doesn't seem to want to be
bothered
so i shan't bother it peter hickers
i can now fly when i sleep
i'm gonna guess you can't oh i'm gonna
guess you can't
oh shut up hello what's up with you i
used to love funny clowns but now they
seem evil to me
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah i know i don't know if i'm supposed
to do something about the thing under
the bed
zoom ah i was supposed to zoom in on it
i
saw you oh oh hey bud oh
all right funny clowns
oh hey i didn't want to come back here
you'd think that i would prefer this to
the child's bedroom but i do not
okay well there's luggage in my way
oh it's gone
who the hell did that
tell me right now open this damn door
something's behind me isn't it no i'm
not seeing it
oh hi oh hey hey
come on peekaboo
oh hi pic oh
yeah oh
no no no no don't come any closer
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
hi did you notice that thing that
was just behind you look out look out
small child
all right i'm gonna run away like a
smart adult get dead
oh nice ass
uh well this is it oh
act two don't be oh that was just act
one oh they weren't joking when they
said this was sizable
okay you guys don't do nothing
and definitely don't get me demonetized
they're just mannequins doesn't matter
if they're naked
they're just mannequins oh great youtube
gods
don't demonetize me for these boobaloos
and nice
they are not real
[Laughter]
very fake hey hi i was going on over
there
okay all right ah chained up well that
doesn't
make a difference from the last time
that anything was a thing
okay any of you guys got a crowberry
bolt cutters
don't mind me just walking by a crotch
level ah
perfect i need the right key
all right it's hidden within the butt
cracks of
one of these mannequins i'll have to go
through them all hey any guys got a
key
guys got a key
key you guys may be holding a key in
your hand
you gotta keep i'll take that
oh i can't make any more mistakes wait
what do you mean mistakes
what oh they all got keys
well that's clearly not right
uh-huh um
how about this one no no no
not right at all no no
no not right at all
what is happening
do you have the right is this the right
key
this seems like the right key
i'm taking it thank you for your
contribution
no no
[Music]
no oh
hey it's you again okay i'll
go goodbye oh god excuse me it's such a
scuse me
ever sub excuse me excuse me
excuse me all right thank you papa
tipato
and i'm free
[Music]
i'll do this
oh hi mom
what
what how was i supposed to know that i
wasn't supposed to do that you put a big
red lever in my face you expect me not
to pull it
you expect me not to pull it you expect
not me to grab it and pull it
okay well try to uh mom's gonna be real
pissed with me if i do that again
so i better not
okay well i got enough beans here to
last me a while so i guess i'm okay
i see monsters in my room my mother
didn't believe me and locked me in the
basement
well i guess that does solve the problem
of the monsters in my room there must be
something else in here that i need
that could help me but what
i say but what i pray
tell me where to go wait
what wait what
oh
i'm sorry i'm sorry
oh hey hey there booby mannequins
so i'm in another reality oh
that's handy thank you for that
thank you wait wait a minute
wait wait a minute
wait wait a minute oh
bigfoot oh who are you
barbara finch for as long as i can
remember my mother has always been
acting strangely
that's not what you said before so your
mom's just weird
it's not really as long as you can
remember your mom's just plain old weird
oh hello oh
oh oh
hi again hey what's up
it's your boy
don't mind if i just take a nap do you
you don't mind if i take a nap
okay good
okay what's in it i don't know
why not open her up
okay later friends
show oh
hey hold it there buckarino
hold it right there pal
uh-huh okay
oh oh oh
hey
hey what you just feel like i hadn't had
a jump scare in a while
i'll prove to my mom that i didn't make
this up didn't make what up
i have to think about my behavior but
only me only
scarier here me and big scary too you
know
me and hi mom bye mom
a woman in a blue dress whispered to him
be strong my white knife or there's a
struggle ahead of you for the green
menus
what
okay i'll take a nap again
[Music]
need to find a way what what
what oh what act three big [ __ ]
what what what
what what
what oh that was funny
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hi bye need to look around do
i what about this dude what do i need to
look around for
what do i need what do i need to look
around for
what okay i'm gonna go look around i
guess
hi am i supposed to avoid you
i feel like i might be supposed to avoid
you so i'm gonna avoid you
who left a bolt cutter on a swing need
the attract
need to run the attraction oh do i
oh is that what i oh well i'm doomed
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what lexing does this make any sense to
you
think real hard think harder
harder harder
let me know when you get any conclusions
did your brain explode
missing fuse okay so somewhere
here there's a fuse
ah you can't see me you can't see me
okay so you can't avoid him let me see
where this mannequin has
you got something for me you got
anything for me a knife
i'll take that hell yeah knife
but now what do i do with the knife do i
kill the clown
do i murder the clown is it murder
yes it's the only way
murder
oh something besides murder that boy his
name was peter was special
i would never hurt him he was lonely
like me the man he called his father was
a monster
i wanted to save him from this world
okay but did you though
but did you did you though
but did you though
i used to go to this park with my dad
but after that
incident i never went back there my life
is
full of tragedy and sorrow the likes of
which you could never comprehend
woes mean all my ilk
my life is pain ah hello
i brought friends with him and brought a
lot of toys and food i wanted to be a
real
father to him he shouldn't have felt bad
and he was happy
i did everything for this the other kids
were misbehaving and i had to calm them
down
i don't understand why they call me a
maniac kids
love clowns yeah okay
sure whatever you say buddy okay so
what is this the boy who disappeared six
days ago was found by local residents
it was discovered in an abandoned hot
outside the city
near the park according to the boy he
was kidnapped by a man dressed as a
clown
when he was on a holiday with his father
okay sure i lived in the cage for six
days i have two other children with me
but i was the only one who survived
at home i began to have nightmares then
i learned to control sleep i try to
forget about those days
one of those things definitely
correlates with all of the others
but where do i go what do i do
how do i escape the clown how really how
do i do it
oh here
oh my god
okay thank you ah i see
okay that should have been a bit more
clear maybe but i thought it had
something to do with that
okay so i have a few so i can run this
thing so i can get bolt cutters to
cut the locks off of that box and then
have a real good time with whatever's in
the box
and that's what i'm here for you'll
never find me
you better not be coming over here oh
you [ __ ]
don't ah
don't even think about how you stuck oh
he's not stuck
okay come on come on come on ah you
stalk you stalk you stupid clown
stupid clown man this this ride is not
safe
for children or adults for that matter
all right get me out of this hell hole
to snap ka-pop
someone in there hey mom
my dark secret
okay all right all right ma
ma you gonna be mad at me if i do
something my
hey it's my bedroom man hey look it's my
bedroom
hey look it's the clown hey look
okay yeah throw those away yeah that'll
that'll show them
all right ma need to make a trap for the
monster here need to find a bell and a
rope
what are you the monster ma
i'm guessing you're the monster
okay uh-oh i have to continue
hunting the monster okay i get it
i get it he will be able to find a way
out if he follows against
the black darkness okay
follow against the black darkness
a rope i found rope
okay oh boy that's not good
i think i saw belle in my mother's room
did you
i didn't see jack [ __ ] i saw nothing
you a-hole mom
mom mom you got a bell
you got a belmont wow
all right mom okay bye mom
[Music]
oh mom oh hi
okay my you gotta clean your bathroom
oh my you forgot your glasses oh
well i have a bell
[Music]
i'll guess oh why that'll stop it
that'll stop it time for sleep
okay after three hours
sure okay
what happened i'm sorry what happened
oh my
oh ma no ma
oh man
[Music]
oh i'm in the basement again apparently
why
hey pals hey how you doing hey
i hid the body here i need to board up
the passes to this room
of course i blame
i'm done now nothing like a hard day's
work
well i'm out madness and
sure it do do it are you sure about that
oh my ankles
don't look behind you run
i don't know which way is behind me
which way is behind me
which way is behind me which way's
behind me
i don't know which way's behind me i'm
running
you lie down me
die uh well you know that's not as easy
as it sounds
well i guess i'm
gonna just pop a squat down here and uh
wait for me to get to my destination i
avoided the underground subways so i
could no longer face my fears until this
day i managed to cope with them
coping is hoping ah
hi how you doing hey
oh some
something unknown scared me i was afraid
of non-existent monsters and it was just
my imagination i didn't want to believe
that my mother was a real monster well
this is a lot of
truth i'm not sure if i'm prepared
i'm not sure if i'm prepared for it
after i was abducted by a maniac in a
clown costume my consciousness separated
from reality
and i began to plunge into the astral
the astral
oh and
tonight two patients escaped from a
psychiatric hospital
a man and a woman they present
themselves as a married couple entered
in trust and can harm others
be careful not to come into contact with
them if you suspect anything call the
local police
all right ah
the people depicted in the photos were
my real parents i couldn't put it
together then because i was too young to
understand but i understand now i don't
understand anything
oh yeah how's your ass
good good
oh no the red sun lights up the path of
the white knight he will be able to find
a way out
if he falls against the black darkness
blue and the blue dress whispered to him
be strong my white knight for there was
a struggle ahead of you for the green
meadows the knight found a way out
how to free the flower meadows to do
this he needs to return to the dark land
and defeat the black witch
and he did then the sun shone a bright
yellow light freeing every corner of the
grass
of the green earth from the darkness
there was no grass
hey wait a minute there's a puzzle it's
puzzle
i s ah it's puzzle we got butthole cross
star syringe cross triangle
butthole crosshairs okay i got it
we got butthole we got
butt hole cross
cross star
syringe ah
triangle no butt hole
oh
cross i'm not awake
that was it i got it i don't need to
look again and i won't look again lixie
and prove that i won't look again by
removing my eyes
can i have him back please thank you
okay
butthole cross
star syringe
cross
triangle schwab
no oh yeah right
butthole crosshairs nailed it i'm the
best
hi how you doing
okay good hey hey what's up
[Music]
am i awake now have i finally woken up
oh peter are you ready to talk
about your childhood today
no no i'm not from an early age my life
was a nightmare
after my mother disappeared i lived in
an orphanage
i didn't tell anyone what really
happened
do you still have nightmares
at the shelter my nightmare stopped i
couldn't
stop thinking that i'd killed my mother
i've lived with this pain
this guilt all my life now i found out
that it was runaway psychos who killed
my real parents
when i was very young and took over our
lives
it wasn't me was runaway psychos
how did you know that today after all
these years
i went astral again i saw everything
that happened to me
at that time is that where you met
her and uh what happened next
i conquered her and overcame my fears
and i realized that when i was a child
i actually saved myself i didn't kill
anyone
i don't think so oh
[Music]
oh
there was so much going on in that there
was just
so much happening like
not a joke i've never played a horror
game where just
so much was going on all at once and it
was pretty good
i feel like it lost a little bit because
of the chaos but honestly like
i enjoyed the experience even though
like it had like these moments where
like so much was happening
and then suddenly nothing was happening
and you were like trying to find
something
like little minutiae things that was
like a bit jarring but
in an entire experience there was just
an astronomical
amount of stuff going on there so i
loved it
i actually did like it i liked it a lot
you know it's it's definitely taking the
normal like horror game
demos that are usually like five ten
minutes and expanding it into a full
experience
i felt like it was great like it was a
little rough around the edges in terms
of some of the things
especially like the exploring parts but
when you were on the subway and things
were happening
i didn't know which way to turn but
every way i turned i got a scare
like here's another one so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play this for yourself link is
in the description
uh check out distractible oh we got good
stuff
that's the worst sales [ __ ] i've ever
had for distractible in my life
hey we got good stuff guys anyway if you
want to watch more scary games that i
played
uh link is in the description or
suggested videos down there thank you
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you